vor mehr als 10.000 jahren haben
menschen begonnen pflanzen nicht nur in
der natur zu sammeln sondern sie auch
selbst anzubauen
so konnten wir uns niederlassen hat
einen gesicherten nahrung und deswegen
höhere überlebenschancen als die jäger
und sammler die wir vorher waren mehr
oder weniger gezielt wurden dann genau
die pflanzen angebaut die besonders
widerstandsfähig waren oder ob einfach
größer wurden auch wenn gene damals noch
unbekannt waren die züchtung war der
erste gezielte eingriff in die evolution
durch genetische selektion fast forward
ins jahr 2020 und wir stehen vor einem
weiteren großen schritt der die natur
für immer verändern könnte
mittlerweile ist es uns möglich die
perfekte nutzpflanze einfach selber zu
bauen und zwar durch chris backus nein
dabei handelt es sich um eine neue
methode der gentechnik bestehend aus
einer kombination von einem schieren
ehrlichen proteinen und eine mehrheit
mit der ich mir aussuchen kann wo ich
präzise einschnitte an der dna
durchführen möchte deswegen wird chris
backus nein auch als gen schere
bezeichnet und nicht nur die natur auch
wir menschen können uns durch chris
backus nein für immer verändern zum
guten oder zum schlechten
wie funktioniert das genau können wir
damit die umwelt retten gibt es bald so
etwas wie designer babys und vor allem
in was für einer welt leben wir wenn wir
jeden organismus verändern können
darum geht es heute in einem neuen video
auf doktor watson
[Musik]
alle organismen von einzellern pflanzen
tieren oder menschen haben lange
moleküle in sich die dna der genetische
code
sie liefert quasi den bauplan von
lebewesen so können wissenschaftler
organismen besser verstehen aber auch
verändern und die auswirkungen dann an
den lebewesen selber sehen wenn man zum
beispiel den bauplan für einen kunden
leuchtendes protein in die dna eines
bakteriums setzt dann wird das bakterium
dieses protein produzieren und anfangen
grün zu leuchten
so zumindest in der theorie praktisch
ist es gar nicht so einfach neue
baupläne in eine dna zu pflanzen weil
man einen organismus verändern möchte
müssen wissenschaftler an die dna aus
den zellen kommen ohne dabei den
organismus selber zu töten aber fun fact
zellen können es gar nicht leiden wenn
man eine reihe fremder dna stränge in
sie hinein stoff für einen organismus
ist das eine bedrohung und die strenge
werden zerstört damit sie angenommen
werden müssen die modifizierten strenge
quasi unter gemogelt werden
dafür muss die dna von einem lebewesen
aufgebrochen werden und es muss dafür
gesorgt werden dass der organismus
bereit ist dieses loch mit der fremden
modifizierten dna zu reparieren
hier stehen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vor zwei hindernissen
erstens die zelle und zweitens die dna
in die zelle kommen wissenschaftler zum
beispiel mit hilfe von elektrizität oder
sogar seife so wird die zellmembran kurz
geöffnet
sowas funktioniert aber nicht bei
menschen sondern eher bei bakterien und
einzellern in die dna zu kommen ist noch
mal schwieriger mit bestimmten enzymen
zb die restriktionen enzymen oder sogar
mit uv licht geht das bereits aber das
ist teilweise unberechenbar präzise
einschnitte in die dna sind super
schwierig wenn zum beispiel die dna in
der mitte eines gens bericht dann stirbt
die ganze zelle und der ganze aufwand
war für die katz
und genau hier kommt chris beck essen
rein ins spiel ursprünglich ist christa
eine verteidigungsstrategie von
bakterien
wenn diese nämlich von einem virus
befallen werden dann doch das virus an
die zelle an und schloss seine dna
hinein
so gelangt das virus in das erbgut und
sorgt auf diese art und weise für die
produktion von ganz ganz vielen neuen
viren um sich gegen das virus zu
verteidigen prägen sich bakterien den
erreger ein und können so eine immunität
entwickeln
enzyme schneiden dafür ein stück aus der
viren dna heraus und bauen ist an einer
ganz bestimmten stelle im bakterien ab
das nennt man den kasper abschnitt die
zelle übersetzt diesen abschnitt dann in
1 rna moleküle die tristen arm rna und
dna sind ein eingespieltes team
die dna ist so was wie der
informationsspeicher während die rna auf
die informationen in der dna zugreift
und sie transportiert und übersetzt
verbindet sich die trissenaar mit einem
zweiten molekül der treysaer rna finden
sich die beiden moleküle ein ganz
bestimmtes enzym kers nein und das ist
die eigentliche schere
dieses enzym kann das bakterium jetzt
gegen das eben erwähnte virus schützen
die christen die aus der virus der nahe
gewonnen wurde gibt also dem kern ein
protein eine anleitung wo es die viren
die anlage genau schneiden soll
damit ist die zelle nicht mehr gefallen
kann das funktioniert allerdings nur
wenn auch die traiser rna an das molekül
gebunden ist
die traiser erna ist also so etwas wie
das gerüst auf dem die christa rna den
kessen ein protein informationen über
das virus zu spielt zwar jetzt alles
relativ kompliziert mit vielen
fachausdrücken ich hoffe dass verstanden
falls nicht ist nicht so schlimm
ihr könnt den rest des videos auch ohne
diesen teil verstehen neue entdeckungen
machen dieses abwehrsystem jetzt aber zu
einem bahnbrechenden werkzeug den
forschenden ist es gelungen die christen
und die traiser rna zu einem einzigen
molekül zu vereinen
dadurch lässt es sich leichter
herstellen der zweite game changer ist
ein modifiziertes kerstin ein protein
das es möglich macht diese methodik auch
in höheren organismen mit zellkern zu
verwenden die auch wir menschen und für
chris backus nein gab es deswegen 2020
den chemienobelpreis dieser wurde unter
anderem an emmanuel chabrier einer
wissenschaftlerin eines max planck
instituts verliehen welche sequenz die
beiden eher ein molekül christa und
tracer besitzen können forscher einfach
austauschen
dadurch lässt sich bestimmen wo gestern
einen dna strang zerschneidet das heißt
beliebige gene können einfach
ausgeschaltet oder sogar komplett
ausgetauscht werden wie ein textdokument
indem man einfach einen tippfehler
ausbessert und mit chris backus nein ist
das wesentlich einfacher und günstiger
als mit allen bisher bekannten techniken
denn es muss lediglich einen eher ein
molekül verändert werden
mit chris backus nein lässt sich also
das erbgut jeder beliebigen zelle
verändern
die gen schere macht die gentechnik
massentauglich und das ist wirklich
krass denn es könnte die beziehung von
mensch und natur für immer verändern und
es deswegen auch ziemlich umstritten
aber komm wir erstmal dazu wie chris
park essen eingesetzt werden könnte
bereits jetzt wird die gen schere für
die grundlagenforschung und
wissenschaftliche experimente in laboren
ziemlich viel genutzt richtig spannend
wird es wenn es um nutzpflanzen geht
hier könnte man mit gezielter
veränderungen der gene neue arten von
nutzpflanzen kreieren
dadurch könnten ackerflächen eingespart
werden oder pflanzen widerstandsfähiger
gegen die einflüsse des klimawandels
gemacht werden
praktisch sieht das dann so aus meist
zum beispiel hat die super nervige
eigenschaft bei wassermangel das
wachstum einzustellen
um dieses problem zu umgehen war für
wissenschaftler ein bestimmtes protein
interessanter said das sorgt bei meist
dafür dass die empfindlichkeit der
zellen gegenüber dem wachstumshormon
ethylen sinkt produziert die pflanze
mehr aggressiv protein reagiert sie bei
stress robuster und stellt nicht wie
sonst bei wassermangel das wachstum ein
mit der christbaum methode gelang es den
schalter des aid protein so
umzuschreiben dass es unter
stressbedingungen aktiv bleibt und der
so editierte meist dann bessere erträge
liefert das heißt mehr meist für alle
ziemlich meist oder chris backus nein
könnte also einer drohenden hungersnot
durch den klimawandel den kampf ansagen
schon jetzt sind 50 prozent der
hungernden weltweit bauern die nicht
genug für sich und ihre familien
produzieren können hier könnte die gegen
schwere bessere pflanzen liefern die
eine sichere und größere ernte
versprechen oder man benutzt die gegen
schere um pflanzen so zu verändern dass
sie auf geringeren raum mehr ertrag
liefern
stichwort urban gardening und vertical
farming auch die resistenz gegenüber
schädlingen könnte man einfach feind
schulen du bist nur intolerant oder
leidet an zirkuliert wir könnten die
gene die für die gluten produktion
notwendig sind aus der dna von weizen
einfach raus schnipseln ihr seht die
möglichkeiten sind beinahe endlos ok
lebensmittelpflanzen mit christa
genetisch zu verändern wäre ein
gewaltiger schritt aber es geht sogar
noch gewaltiger was wenn man einfach die
dna eines menschen so verändert dass
dieser gar nicht erst allergisch wird
technisch gesehen steht dem nichts im
wege
aber natürlich gibt es einwände denn
eben weil sich mit christa kessler
theoretisch jeder organismus verändern
lässt ist die gegenstände so extrem
kontrovers einerseits unter
wissenschaftlern aber auch das
öffentliche image von christa ist
umstritten
wir haben euch mal auf instagram gefragt
welche fragen hier für dieses video
hierzu christa kessler habt und ein
großteil von euch macht sich vor allem
sorgen
im kern machen sich ein paar von euch
aber auch wissenschaftler journalisten
und politiker sorgen dass wir mit chris
backus nein in einer designerbaby
dystopie leben würden
das heißt schon vor der geburt stelle
ich die weichen um einen menschen ganz
nach meinen vorstellungen zur welt zu
bringen augenfarbe keine erbkrankheiten
vielleicht sogar körperbau oder
intelligenz alles kann irgendwie
angepasst werden
so weit so gut da ist natürlich nur das
problem der gerechtigkeit
solche verfahren kosten geld und kann
sich das jeder leisten natürlich nicht
das was wir jetzt als immer größer
werdende schere zwischen arm und reich
bezeichnen könnte dann nicht nur einen
unterschied der lebensqualität bedeuten
sondern ein unterschied der auch
äußerlich sichtbar ist wohlhabende
eltern können ihren kindern gesundheit
ein aussehen nach dem schönheitsideal
und vielleicht sogar bessere fähigkeiten
und mehr intelligenz schenken während
ärmere familien bis hin zu ganzen
ländern die genetische lotterie spielen
müssen
zu diesem thema habe ich übrigens mit
einer expertin für ethik den film
gattaca gekuckt einer meiner
lieblingsfilme und mit ihr über die
folgen von genmanipulation gesprochen
das video könnt ihr euch hier oben
anschauen eingriffe mit christian
menschen könnten aber auch bedeuten
menschen vor krankheiten zu schützen
und hier kann sich die ethische
diskussion um 180 grad wenden
denn durch die gegen schwere könnte es
theoretisch möglich sein dass niemand
mehr unter einer angeborenen krankheit
leiden muss bei krankheiten vor der
geburt einfach aus der dna entfernt
werden
je nachdem können wir uns dann fragen
wäre es ethisch vertretbar nicht
einzugreifen
immerhin haben wir die chance menschen
ein leben ohne schizophrenie trisomie 21
oder herzfehler zu bescheren
und die wird es noch schwieriger ist ein
gesundes leben das einzig lebenswerte
kann man nicht auch mit trisomie 21 ein
glückliches und erfülltes leben führen
das sind fragen mit denen wir uns als
gesellschaft beschäftigen müssen die nur
teilweise noch nicht geklärt sind und
sich vielleicht auch gar nicht klären
lassen während die möglichkeiten dafür
aber schon da sind die wissenschaft
überholt uns hier ein bisschen also
lassen wir das mal zusammen mit chris
backus nein lässt sich praktisch jeder
organismus editieren
das kann die wirtschaft für immer
verändern hungersnot bekämpfen und uns
menschen gesünder machen
aber mit großer macht kommt auch große
verantwortung oder so ähnlich denn eben
weil die gen schere so viel so
zugänglich verändern kann
machen sich wissenschaftler sorgen wie
weit können wir gehen wollen wir ihnen
das leben eingreifen ist christa er eine
riesige chance
oder doch eher eine große gefahr der
erste eingriff in die menschliche dna
soll übrigens schon längst stattgefunden
haben nach eigenen angaben hat ein
chinesischer wissenschaftler bereits
ende 2018 zwillinge mit hilfe von chris
backus immun gegen den aids erreger hiv
gemacht das ist allerdings nur eine
behauptung es wurde nie wissenschaftlich
nachgewiesen dass das wirklich so
passiert ist
trotzdem ist damals ein echter schock
durch die wissenschaft gegangen denn
hier war der zumindest westliche konsens
dass solche versuche mit chris backus
nein noch mindestens 10 bis 15 jahre in
der zukunft liegen und man sich so viel
zeit wie möglich nehmen sollte um die
gen schere und vor allem auch ihre
auswirkungen besser zu verstehen
dem wissenschaftler wurde vorgeworfen
sämtliche ethische grundsätze der
biomedizin einfach über den haufen
geworfen zu haben
über mögliche risiken ist halt einfach
noch viel zu wenig bekannt
so ein eingriff könnte verheerende
folgen nicht nur für den ruf von chris
bahn sondern auch für den erfolg von
gentechnik haben
vielleicht würde man schädliche folgen
der ersten genveränderung am menschen
erst in zehn oder 15 jahren sehen
vielleicht sogar erst wenn diese
menschen selber kinder oder enkelkinder
bekommen aber egal wie weit solche
folgen in der zukunft liegen das würde
die akzeptanz für gehen veränderungen
und insbesondere die space nine komplett
zunichte machen
so verspielt man sich das vertrauen von
der bevölkerung ok also nicht okay aber
okay ist chris beck es jetzt gut oder
schlecht wieder noch es ist in erster
linie ein werkzeug das wissenschaftler
gerade erst einmal genauer kennen lernen
möchten und ob dieses werkzeug
gefährlich oder hilfreich ist hängt
davon ab wie man es verwendet das ist so
ähnlich wie mit einem hammer den kann
man dafür benutzen um etwas neues zu
bauen da etwas zu reparieren oder um
etwas kaputt zu machen
das soll für chris bad essen natürlich
nicht bedeuten dass böse wissenschaftler
in ihren geheimverstecken der menschheit
schaden wollen in erster linie ist die
größte gefahr hier leichtsinnigkeit
duisburg essen ein macht es so einfach
unüberlegte potenziell gefährliche
eingriffe viel zu früh durchzuführen
deswegen hat man sich zumindest
innerhalb der eu auf das vorsorgeprinzip
geeinigt das heißt chris beck essen ein
soll umweltschädigende und
gesundheitliche folgen angewandt werden
man mahnt zur vorsicht in eu klappt das
schon ganz gut aber beispielsweise china
wird in den nächsten jahren ein
unausweichlicher forschungs magnet
werden
es braucht internationale ökologische
medizinische und ethische standards wie
wir die gen scheren benutzen wollen nur
so profitieren wir am ende alle
vielleicht von besseren lebensmitteln
weniger erbkrankheiten und vielleicht
einer besseren welt oder auch eben nicht
sollte die grundlagenforschung in den
nächsten jahren zu einem ergebnis kommen
dass chris beckers nein verheerende
mutationen in den folgegenerationen
hervorruft dann werden wir alle dankbar
sein dass sich die wissenschaften so
viel zeit genommen hat wie sie braucht
um vielleicht eine der größten
entdeckungen der menschheitsgeschichte
erstmal zu verstehen
neben chris backus nein gibt es aber
auch noch eine handvoll anderer dinge
die unser leben in den nächsten zehn
jahren vielleicht verändern werden neue
arten der ernährung die mobilität der
zukunft oder sogar die ersten cyborgs
bis 2030 könnte einiges passieren
darüber haben wir schon ein video
gemacht das könnt ihr euch gerne hier
anschauen ansonsten nicht vergessen den
kanal zu abonnieren um kein neues video
mehr zu verpassen
das hier war sie nun die vierte und
damit letzte folge unserer serie für das
wissenschaftsjahr 2020 bioökonomie in
den anderen drei folgen haben sie unter
anderem über die stadt der zukunft
gesprochen
die ganz anders aussieht als man sich
das vielleicht vorstellt wenn euch diese
videos noch mal anschauen wollt wir
haben eine playlist verlinkt da sind
dann alle vier videos drin und mich
interessiert natürlich eure meinung
lasst uns mal in den kommentaren
diskutieren ist chris backus nein eine
chance oder eher eine riesige gefahr
danke an das bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung und die
gemeinnützige organisation wissenschaft
im dialog für die unterstützung bei
diesem video und auch bei den drei
anderen videos in dieser serie
ansonsten hat euch danke fürs zuschauen
und bleibt immer neugierig cedric